[Music]  it's time for a tease social study a  quick look at everything the stars have  been posting online I'm excited about it  Kylie Jenner went nearly makeup free in  this sweet snap with Caitlyn Jenner had  Jay Leno's Garage while her pal hailey  Baldwin got sexy for love magazines  advent calendar meanwhile Chris Pratt  got silly with this throwback pics he  captured it here a young Chris Pratt  poses on the red carpet wearing designer  funny ears and blue vest by goodwill of  America President Obama got pranked by  his White House staff with these kind of  creepy snowmen Miley Cyrus and Liam  Hemsworth enjoyed a little Cyrus family  time for the holidays and Miley's fellow  the voice coach Blake Shelton looked at  Christmas lights and cooked with  girlfriend Gwen Stefani goddess-like van  with her Michael Phelps shared yet  another adorable shot of his son boomer  and Amy Schumer sent courtside at the  Knicks game with some famous pals yeah  it's really exciting  [Music]